[Música]
bienvenidos a un nuevo capítulo de
áfrica siete días aquí en france 24 este
es un magacín informativo 100% dedicado
al continente africano mi nombre liliana
valencia que damos una mirada en
profundidad los hechos de actualidad de
la semana en la cuna de la humanidad
el gobierno de etiopía emitió un
comunicado asegurando que continuará con
el llenado de la denominada mega represa
del renacimiento por segundo año
consecutivo con aguas del nilo azul
principal afluente del río nilo por
supuesto el río principal del continente
africano esto a pesar de las
conversaciones con los gobiernos de
egipto y sudán que no avanzan de la
mejor manera el ejército de mozambique
recupera el control de la ciudad de la
palma después de un ataque yihadista que
dejó decenas de muertos cientos de
desaparecidos y también de desplazados
ahora las familias se esperan en la
ciudad vecina de pemba una solución por
parte del gobierno que ha prometido
ayudas para estos desplazados el
presidente de francia manuel macro le
ordenó la desclasificación de una serie
de documentos relacionados con el papel
del país galo en el genocidio de ruanda
el mandatario emprende así un proceso de
revisión del pasado colonial de la
nación en el continente africano
iniciamos entonces con la información en
áfrica siete días las conversaciones
entre sudán etiopía y egipto bajo la
mediación de la unión africana acerca de
la denominada mega represa del
renacimiento no han sido exitosas las
tres naciones tienen una disputa de
larga data sobre el llenado de la
hidroeléctrica construida por etiopía el
proyecto ha sacado a relucir una disputa
mayor compartir o no las aguas del río
nilo
una pelea que lleva años es el agua
vital para millones de personas
el recurso aquí en disputa y más
específicamente qué cantidad de las
aguas del río nilo se pueden almacenar y
apartar en etiopía en lugar de fluir
hacia egipto y sudán en 2011 etiopía
inició la construcción de la represa con
una capacidad de 74 mil millones de
metros cúbicos de agua el proyecto de
infraestructura de 5 mil millones de
dólares es un motivo de orgullo para el
país africano una vez terminada será la
represa hidroeléctrica más poderosa de
áfrica pero el embalse se conecta con el
nilo azul el principal afluente del río
nilo que proporciona casi toda el agua
de la que dependen egipto y sudán en
marzo el presidente egipcio dijo que su
país está unido sobre la necesidad de
establecer límites
tuvimos la misma posición de rechazar
los intentos de etiopía de imponer como
un hecho cumplido lo del nilo azul a
través de medidas unilaterales que no
tienen en cuenta los derechos de los dos
países aguas abajo la semana pasada el
mandatario advirtió sobre una
inestabilidad que nadie puede imaginar
si se saca una sola gota de agua de
egipto una amenaza de conflicto no está
descartada y es una idea que permaneció
en el trasfondo de la última ronda de
conversaciones mientras los ministros
negociaban sobre la velocidad a la que
se llenará el embalse como se repondrá
cada año y exactamente cuánta agua se
liberaría si hubiera una sequía
importante
egipto quiere un acuerdo legalmente
vinculante que establezca los términos
futuros algo con lo que etiopía no está
totalmente de acuerdo también se negocia
quien debería supervisar las futuras
disputas sudán y egipto quieren
mediadores como la unión europea eeuu y
la onu junto con la unión africana para
ayudar a resolver cualquier desacuerdo
pero etiopía dice que cree en resolver
los problemas africanos con las naciones
del continente
este 11 de abril dos países africanos
realizaron elecciones presidenciales en
medio de las medidas de prevención por
la pandemia de kobe 19 se trata de venir
y chad donde una vez cerradas las urnas
inició el conteo de los votos
bienvenidos ciudadanos solo pudieron
votar entre las tres candidaturas
aceptadas por la comisión nacional
electoral autónoma los comicios
estuvieron marcados por la baja
asistencia a los colegios electorales
durante la jornada no se registraron
incidentes pese a las manifestaciones
pre electorales en contra de un posible
segundo mandato del actual presidente
patrice talón que dejaron un saldo de
dos personas muertas en charla
participación en las presidenciales
también fue baja y las votaciones se
llevaron a cabo en medio de un fuerte
operativo policial y militar el
presidente idriss deby busca un sexto
mandato y la comisión electoral nacional
independiente tiene hasta el próximo 25
de abril para anunciar los resultados de
esta primera vuelta
el ejército de mozambique aseguró haber
retomado el control de la ciudad de
palma en el norte del país sumida en la
violencia tras los ataques yihadistas
del pasado 24 de marzo según las fuerzas
de seguridad las tropas gubernamentales
han matado a un alto número de
insurgentes y han despejado la zona
una ciudad desolada por los ataques
luego de días de enfrentamientos el
ejército de mozambique retomó el control
de la estratégica ciudad costera de
palma en el norte del país que había
sido capturada por los yihadistas de al
shabab el pasado 24 de marzo el gobierno
dijo que ahora es una ciudad segura
después de matar a un importante número
de insurgentes sensibles
hemos completado la limpieza era la
única zona sensible que teníamos que
despejar es completamente segura en las
próximas horas si necesitamos traer
algún avión con alimentos para la
población se podrá hacer sin problemas
es seguro ser usadas en el programa
casi dos semanas después de los peores
ataques desde 2017 patrocinados por la
insurgencia es la amistad filial local
del autodenominado estado islámico el
número de muertos sigue sin conocerse
según naciones unidas unos 11.000
civiles han sido desplazados
forzosamente la violencia en la
localidad pero el número podría ser
mayor
muchos supervivientes han visto morir a
sus familiares y estuvieron días sin
comer o beber mientras intentaban
escapar which is that seventies y lo que
sabemos es que alrededor del 76 por
ciento de las personas que hemos
conseguido evacuar son
mujeres y niños y obviamente en el
propio cabo delgado ha habido
desnutrición crónica durante años y
sabemos que 950 mil personas sufren
inseguridad alimentaria cuando
enfatizamos en people of fire in situ o
el distrito donde se encuentra palma
está diaz ente a multimillonarios
proyectos de gas natural debido a la
violencia yihadista el gigante francés
total ha abandonado su proyecto allí y
ha retirado a su personal de trabajo
mientras que el ejército dijo que estaba
protegiendo sus instalaciones cuatro
integrantes del cuerpo de paz de la
misión de las naciones unidas en mali
perdieron la vida en un ataque los
hechos ocurrieron en una base militar en
el norte del país cerca a la localidad
de agua los otros siete soldados
resultaron heridos en dicho ataque la
misión de la onu conocida como la misma
no dio más detalles de cómo ocurrieron
los hechos y quién pudo haberlos
perpetrado mal y vides de 2012 el avance
de los grupos yihadistas en el norte del
país que ha generado una grave crisis de
seguridad y miles de muertos en la
región
el 6 de abril de 1994 el avión del
presidente ruandés juvenal habyarimana
fue derribado con su muerte y visión
genocidio en el que murieron 800.000
personas pertenecientes a la etnia tutsi
el informe nuclear encargado por el
presidente francés emmanuel macrón
calificó de fracaso rotundo lo sucedido
en ruanda para la política exterior
francesa en ese sentido macrón quiere
revisar el pasado colonial de su país y
por eso torneo la clasificación de
documentos del ministerio de defensa
desde 1971
27 años de una de las mayores
atrocidades en la historia de la
humanidad francia conmemora el genocidio
de ruanda que dejó entre abril y julio
de 1994 más de 800.000 tutsis y hutus
moderados masacrados coincidiendo con el
aniversario francia ha hecho de dominio
público cerca de 8.000 documentos
oficiales sobre el papel del estado
francés entre 1990 y 1994 en ruanda
antes en marzo una comisión de
historiadores publicó un informe
encargado por macrón para esclarecer lo
sucedido
si la foto de pacú aunque francia no es
cómplice el acto criminal del genocidio
su acción contribuyó a que éste
sucediera y al no saberlo ni entenderlo
esto es una gran responsabilidad
intelectual es aceituno innovamos
responsabilitat erigieron en guisos y
ruanda el presidente paul kagamé también
conmemora el aniversario del genocidio y
kagamé un rebelde la minoría tutsi ha
gobernado el país desde el año 2000 con
la llegada de macrón y su política de
revisión histórica han mejorado las muy
tensas relaciones entre países sin
embargo
ruandeses no se conforman de muchos
jefes había importantes declaraciones en
el informe de uclés pero termina con el
rechazo de la complicidad de francia
aunque todos somos muy conscientes de lo
que sucedió francia ha estado contra los
tutsis antes durante y después del
genocidio así que lo que esperamos es
una fuerte clara y verdadera disculpa
del presidente francés esto
en este sentido se cree que hay más de
100 perpetradores del genocidio en
francia sin embargo sólo han sido
condenadas tres personas y se espera que
otras cuatro vayan a juicio
y varios de los más importantes reyes y
reinas que gobernaron egipto hace unos
3000 años fueron protagonistas del
desfile de dorado en el cairo
la procesión forma parte de la apuesta
del milenario país africano por atraer a
los turistas después de que esta
industria se viera muy afectada por la
pandemia en total 22 momias fueron
trasladadas en un para único desfile
hacia su nueva morada en el museo
nacional de la civilización egipcia
uno a uno los monarcas más antiguos de
egipto rodearon la plaza tahrir en una
extravagante muestra del rico patrimonio
del país 22 momias reales fueron
transportadas desde el museo egipcio
donde habían recibido durante más de un
siglo a su nueva residencia de descanso
en el museo nacional de la civilización
egipcia hemos elegido el museo de la
civilización porque queremos por primera
vez exponer las momias de forma
civilizada de forma educada y no para
divertirse como se hacía en el museo
egipcio el convoy del desfile dorado
constaba de 18 faraones y 4 reinas la
mayoría pertenecían al antiguo reino
nuevo que gobernó egipto entre el año
1500 39 antes de cristo y el año 1000 75
antes de cristo- con una banda militar
bailarines y guardias a caballo el
desfile se caracterizó por la pompa y la
fastuosidad a los que estas figuras
estuvieron alguna vez acostumbradas y
viajaron con estilo en vehículos hechos
a medida cada uno de ellos fue
transportado en un contenedor especial
de
apertura controlada para garantizar que
los antiguos miembros de la realeza
pudieran soportar el viaje de una hora
hasta su nuevo hogar sé que tendré está
o segundo el valiente que reinó en el
sur de egipto en el año 1600 antes de
cristo- encabezaba la flota la procesión
también incluye a ramsés segundo uno de
los faraones más famosos del país
la reina hachepsut también se desplazó
en su época superó las barreras de
género para convertirse en una de las
pocas faraones de egipto las autoridades
esperan que el espectacular desfile y
retransmitido en directo in sufre un
nuevo impulso a la industria turística
un sector que se ha visto paralizado por
la pandemia y finalizamos con música que
nos llega desde la república democrática
del congo país de origen de la cantante
de hip hop cristal mls artista presentó
recientemente el nuevo videoclip de su
canción líricas importantes donde
levanta su voz en contra de las
injusticias que viven las mujeres
jóvenes en el mundo radical londres se
ha convertido en una de las voces
femeninas del rap en el reino unido así
finalizamos en áfrica siete días pero
ustedes pueden continuar con más en
nuestra página web www punto frente y
cuatro puntos para ampliar la
información de américa latina y el mundo
nos vemos más adelante con más
información
holley chapman bullying de profesionales
estoy en washington serie este país
manager y en washington funcionarios más
[Música]
los más chicos
informe
además lamentó que sean flores y si las
hay